welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about all the web
dudes inside of toby maguire spider-man
and we know a lot about that for some
reason i'm gonna put some in your eye
[Music]
so many tubes my name is mt and i'm here
today with off-screen producer brandon
one of my favorite people what's going
on brandon hello mt i'll talk to you
anytime i'll swing on over from whatever
reality i'm in to you whatever reality
you're in and we'll just chat it'll be
great that's the nicest thing anyone's
ever said to me thank you brandon wow no
one's ever said they would cross
realities for me oh yeah just saying i
gotta get my exes
just saying listen
listen find you someone who will cross
realities for you okay if someone says
they willing across reality come get you
they don't deserve you they ain't worth
it they ain't worth it
but anyway hit me with that big question
brandon okay i mean mt
what's what's on everyone's minds these
days it's that spider-man no way home
trailer it's finally here you know and
we got some confirmation on some things
that have been speculated about mainly
that we're gonna see some villains from
other spider-man film franchises showing
up in the mcu now there have been rumors
that like other spider-man might be
coming over to the mcu we don't have a
confirmation on that yet but it looks
like maybe we're going that way can we
dream do we dare dream a dream i dare
dream keep the dream alive so if we if
we potentially have all these peter
parkers colliding okay
that would mean that maybe these
variants would have to have some like
conversations about all the little
differences and their realities and how
it meshes with the mcu's reality so that
got us thinking about this week's big
question what variances will have to be
reconciled when multiple peter parkers
collide oh [ __ ]
parker's collide and parker's attack
okay so the rumors might be true we
could potentially see all three peter
parker's in one film three peters one
film better than two girls one cup let
me tell you that one i'm not watching it
again
stop sending it empty
it's the music in that film
so of course we're talking about toby
maguire's original spider-man andrew
garfield skater boy spider-man from the
amazing spider-man series and mcu's
precocious tom holland night monkey
spider-man hybrid night monkey night
monkey night monkey which one is he who
knows maybe this is why a doctor strange
can't figure out the spell it's like
your night monkey your spider-man
i don't know who you are that might have
caused something that's not my spell
it's true it's true but all of these
spider realities had their own unique
variances some characters were present
in only one or two realities while some
appeared in all three and peter has
different love interests across
universes and aunt may owns a house in
some worlds and is happy hogan's main
squeeze and some others so let's go
through the inconsistencies amongst the
peters and see if we can determine what
plot points spider-man no way home might
have to address starting with the web
fluid
so let's say all three peters meet up in
the new film and one of the most
interesting conversations that those
peters would definitely have to have
would be around their web fluid because
they're all scientists after all nerds i
feel like peter doesn't have a lot of
people he can talk about what food with
right
he had to hide it in class he can't talk
about it you know ned knows about it i
guess but
you know this is like an important
moment in any spider-man's transition
from spider-boy to spider-man is when
you learn how to make the web fluid it's
all about the fluid the fluid develops
when you're a teenage boy that's what
they tell you
that's what they warn you oh god all
right
so they're bound to be curious the fluid
is really important too right because
it's it's probably like as a if you're a
comic book fan
to a non-common good person they're like
the webbing
you know what and they're like no he's a
he's a smart boy right he was already a
really smart boy the spider bite made
him a little even smarter and one of the
things he does is figure out how to make
web fluid because you know he's stuck
with the spider-man gimmick so we he's
got to make webs he can't be spider-man
and not have webs otherwise you're just
insects exactly you're bug man and like
i do love that because it showcases that
peter was smart enough to make such
something so incredible as webbs even
without his powers yes so like he was on
a trajectory towards some type of nerdy
greatness already but the only one
problem though one problem
toby maguire never had to figure out how
to make web fluid since it just comes
out of his body i don't know how
i don't know what how that feels but
like it's just really super really gross
how that happened and the scene where he
figures it out is a little weird too
it's a little weird it's it's very weird
it's more of a little weird
[Music]
but look back when toby's movies were
made comic book movies were not the
cultural behemoths that they are today
and audiences weren't as savvy to all
the explanations of strange concepts
that comic books often introduce so it
was just easier to say that spider-man
just makes webb like a spider because he
was bit by a radioactive spider rather
than explain that peter parker is also a
genius who figures out you know chemical
formula for making web but the same
rainbow movies never really explain just
how toby is able to make that web fluid
because spider silk is a protein created
by spiders in special organs called
spinnerets which is also the name of my
uh you know side band where i sing with
a bunch of uh talented um spider-themed
women i'm just like it's emptying the
spinnerets mt and the spinnerets
[Music]
i'm gonna spin you however
[Music]
i'm glad you're bringing this up empty
because this has always like bothered me
like the mechanics of how he's getting
webbed from inside of his body outside
of his body how many calories he needs
to eat a day to make all this webbing
like i hope they talk about it i want i
want a half hour of the movie just to be
explaining this to me right because like
in uh in civil war sam says yeah this
stuff coming out of you so like i really
hope that they lead on that just like
hey does this kind of coming out of you
i really hope sam is there to see toby
mcguire
oh my god i told you i told you i told
you they shoot it out of them
so the spinnerets are an external organ
on the body and in this case it would be
weird bumps on toby's wrist but inside
the spider's body connected to the
spinneret is a gland where the web is
generated like a gel-like fluid and it
doesn't become a solid web until it
exits the body oh so okay you're saying
mt that like those little bumps we saw
in like the first spider-man those are
the spinnerets
on
on toby right and he's got like glands
somewhere
somewhere in his body full of web fluid
the webbed gel like in everyone's body
we all got the gel to make spider webs
of course you all got a web a web gel
sack right and you might be thinking
it's crazy that one spider-man can make
all that web inside of his body but the
darwin's bark spider is capable of
shooting out a web 25 meters long and
that's 82 feet for those who are too
lazy to convert to the metric system why
haven't we done it i don't know anyway
that spider is about you know .6 inches
long like you know something that i own
just kidding
ouch that spider is about point eight
inches long and toby is about five foot
eight so if we extrapolate the size of
the bark spider to toby that means that
toby should have no problem shooting
over six thousand nine hundred and
seventy feet of web that's a lot of
weapons
almost 7 000 feet of web that's over a
mile that's a ton of web dude imagine
him just shooting out a mile of web at
once that would be disgusting he just
like passes that at the end he's like
give me a minute this is like losing
consciousness if you think about like
the train scene right when you stop on
the train he shoots a bunch of web it
breaks that's not enough and then he
shoots like a bunch more and at the end
of it he's kind of tired he passes he's
like it's true he's just like i just
shot all of my goo i got no more goo
left in me no more you gotta carry me i
ain't got no more goo all those extras
you have all those extras that get to
deliver like their one line man and they
just give it they're like he's just a
boy right he's just just a boy look at
him it's spiderman because he's a spider
boy not a spiderman he could be my son i
empathize with him now i mean he just
saved your life guys like cut up some
slack be nice to the boy very strong boy
catch that boy yeah here comes a good
boy kind of a greasy boy no that's a new
york boy the original pizza boy dirty
boy he looks like a normal boy who's
been whittled down what a sweet boy here
you go bloop small boy softboy get up
you guys have boy they made local
newspaper headlines that said hero boy
has good fall toby maguire does not look
like a boy at any point in that
franchise
i'm a man if someone carried a grown-ass
man and said it's just a boy i'd be like
if that guy was walking on my high
school i'd be like that guy's a cop
come on
to be fair everyone at toby maguire's
high school it looks like a college
campus i mean everyone flash looks old
freaking joe manchester rich original
flash before it was a toe for grace
right you know mj looks old everyone
looks old at that high school it's it's
it's a little kooky it's true you have
to know what this place does i don't
know you're a liar you never leave each
other nothing separates us
oh no
technically tom holland is like he's 25
like a 15 year old i don't know how old
i'm talking he looks very cherubish you
know he's a little baby boy it's okay i
believe it i believe it yeah so we gotta
think like toby's probably gotta eat
like a lot a little extra calories uh to
fill up his web fluid sack right uh i
mean i'm sure all the spiderman are
really hungry because they're swinging
around they probably have like pretty
quick metabolisms they got a healing
factor so i'm sure they're all eating a
lot but i bet toby's got to eat like a
little bit more because he's got to make
his own web juice inside of his body
it's true he's got to drink his spider
aid you know he's going to get that
energy up it's pizza time baby you know
he's like stealing some of those pizzas
that he's delivering he's like listen i
gotta do it seriously he's like he's
just ready while he's delivering pizza
it's like come on guy you can't be awake
it's true like if i was toby instead of
like you know having them not pay for
the pizza if it's late i would just grab
the pizza be like you bye if you're not
gonna pay for the pizza you're not
getting the pizza my pizza now i need
the carbs in me for the goo lady i'm not
paying for those i miss the part where
that's my problem
it's gotta be dangerous for toby
spider-man because like you know the
other spider-man they know when like
they're running low on cartridges or
whatever but like toby's like i think i
got enough left inside of me i don't
know let's find out it's like oh [ __ ]
i'm at a goo cause i don't believe in
myself or something i don't know yeah i
would never be spider-man after that i'd
be like yo this thing is not guaranteed
i'm not swinging yeah yeah i'm a
caterpillar man now i walk on the ground
okay so another conversation that is
bound to come up amongst all the council
of peters are the respective love
interests because tom has mj but no gwen
andrew doesn't have an mj and was in
love with gwen but then she got you know
snapped but not by thanos just by
gravity which is arguably worse you
don't come back from that you can't be
gravity you cannot be gravity gravity
always wins um make sure to tell your
vertebrae that tonight gravity
and uh toby has dated both mj and gwen
in his universe because he just got it
like that i mean no because
he's got that
got that black suit you know gwen shows
up he's like all right i know i don't
need this mj trash anymore exactly who
knows how many girlfriends he actually
had in spider-man 3. we just don't know
yeah he was throwing throwing eyes that
is his landlord's daughter you know what
i mean he was giving her exactly he was
he was trying to get them cookies you
know what i'm saying should i get him
get them cookies he wanted to make sure
there was some nuts in them cookies you
know what i'm saying
no absolutely not
tom learning about toby's long-term
involvement with mj could put added
pressure on his current budding
relationship with his mj i could see
like you know tom being like
you know he just got back from europe
everyone knows who he is and now he's
found out that like oh i'm supposed to
be with her it's some weird like
universal destiny thing it could like
totally freak him out you know there is
a lot of things in peter's life that
seems to be constant amongst each
universe right so i think that like you
know especially with another thing we're
gonna talk about next with uncle ben
that's going to really freak him out
yeah for sure because it's like what is
going on why are all the uncle ben's
dead yeah why does god hate uncle ben
quite frankly i'm tired of it but the
most interesting thing here might have
to be how andrew reacts to all of this
because he was the one who lost his love
in the amazing spider-man 2 and probably
feels somewhat responsible for that
because even in the amazing spider-man 2
with the um with the death of gwen
cece's father he was already dealing
with so many so much guilt about hanging
out with gwen stacy when her father told
him to keep her away from all that so
with gwen stacy dead he's just like oh
shoot like
oh daisy given that he could be in the
mcu he could be looking for a gwen stacy
in this reality that hasn't been
revealed yet so like he could be trying
to find her and bring her back to his
reality because he wants you know
himself to feel better and maybe the
stacey family to like not feel the loss
of two family members because they
already lost their dad loki has
established that variants can look the
same they can look different but they
can also look the same you know we'll
talk about it more later with jay jonah
jameson but if if the gwen in this in
the mcu you know is
uh emma stone right uh and he sees her
would he lose his mind would he go crazy
uh would he want to bring her back to
his universe would you want to stay here
so he could be with her even though she
has no idea who he is that's it'd be
really interesting to see how they
handle a spiderweb situation and in like
which version of spider when we'll see
because like you said there is emma
stone but there also is the spider of
the gwen from the from the rainy trilogy
right so like we we don't know which one
right well yeah it's probably going to
be emma stone because let's be real
maybe why why would they bring her in if
they weren't going to use her like
anyway we'll see now let us talk about
aunt bae uncle ben and of course peter
parker's parents because peter's
relationship with his family members has
always been a core issue with this
character and all three versions of
peter parker have had very different
combinations of family members and every
peter has an automate you gotta have an
aunt man you gotta have it which is
great to hear yeah classic though marisa
tomei aunt may might be pissed to hear
that the other aunt mays have houses and
she's stuck in an apartment [ __ ]
it's true give her a house although
uh toby's aunt may she was losing the
house right they had to go to the bank
that was like the whole thing this is
true she's like oh i didn't know i had
to pay property tax it's like sorry lady
sorry landowner you gotta pay property
tax all right it's like i don't give a
[ __ ] how old do you want come on give
him the money you probably paid like 50
for that house 100 years ago come on
this is crap new york city it's crammed
turning into a multi-use uh building
come on lady i think it would be a crazy
twist if what if at the end or like at
some point during spider-man 2 she like
you find out that aunt may paid off uh
doc ock to rob the bank
so she could keep her house from being
for close to cause i don't know who this
man is
i mean he could be walking down the
street i wouldn't
i wouldn't know a thing
it wouldn't be true it could happen that
would be hilarious no offense to sally
field great oscar winner lover obviously
marissa told me
don't tell my wife that's suspicious
but uh
toby's toby's on may was great because
she was just like
sassy she was senile when she needed to
be like oh i didn't know that but she
had attitude she was funny she was a
great on me great on me it just felt
very like comfortable it's like that's
my grandma too yeah that's my odd too
protective like she'll she'll just give
you like you know 20 in a little candy
like little strawberry candies but of
course uncle ben is a really key player
in the development of toby and andrew
spider-man like we were talking about
before but we really haven't learned
much about tom's uncle ben we've only
seen his initials on some luggage which
seemed to subtly confirm his existence
at some point within the mcu and both
toby and andrew spidey lost their uncle
bands in very brutal ways and it had
profound effects on their psyche like
you know with pretty much every
iteration of spider-man and they both
feel responsible for not using their new
abilities to prevent their uncle's death
and this affects how they approach the
great responsibility that comes with
being spider-man we don't know much
about the death of tom's uncle ben he
possibly wasn't even murdered it could
have happened by natural causes we don't
even know but additionally uncle ben's
death could have happened before tom
even got bit by the spider or it could
have happened after and it's possible
that tom doesn't feel the same
responsibility for it that toby and
andrew did it's a huge mystery like what
is up with uncle ben and you're right mt
uncle ben is so important for
both toby and andrew spiderman are so
affected by uncle ben because they you
know they like you said they feel that
responsibility andrew like sees uncle
ben get shy like he sees it across the
street and he could have stopped it but
he just wanted his chocolate milk right
it's crazy
he needs some milk as far as we know tom
spiderman didn't have that right you
know
like you said uncle ben could have
already been dead by the time he got bit
and tony kind of filled that role a
little bit for him also is on may uh but
i think it would be really interesting
for them to all talk about uncle ben uh
because if it does come out that tom was
there and it did play a big part in him
too that would be like fascinating
reveal to finally get uh and we just you
know curious minds want to know what
what happened to uncle ben in the mcu we
gotta know we gotta know we know he
didn't run out on on may
no no living man is gonna leave marissa
toe on me
oh no no way no way absolutely i would i
not ever do that like merced may is
perfect she has my initials and
everything we were meant to be meant to
be together what if we they go back in
time all three peters and they all three
have to watch mcu peter's
uncle ben dies from the sidelines this
is so crucial to our development yeah
that we have to watch it or they take
like they're like you have to see it tom
toby and i toby and andrew we we got
together we took a vote we're gonna take
you back in time you gotta watch
i'm sorry
all right you gotta watch him go you
gotta watch him go
stop being a [ __ ]
why does he who remains kill all these
uncle pence seriously kane just like
loves killing uncle ben just like that
that'll be the the constant throughout
the secret timeline i mean they asked
they asked the eternals you know why
didn't you help with thanos eternals why
don't you help with uncle ben why don't
go back
[Music]
and finally we have peter's parents so
for toby and tom beyond being deceased
not much is known about them but
andrew's parents were much more crucial
in that storyline if you remember in the
amazing spider-man movies they were
killed on purpose because of the
research that they were doing it's like
you know the spider like they were
involved with the origins of spider-man
and andrew garfield spider-man so they
had to
and they were like assassinated like on
purpose right
it would be interesting if like in the
mcu you know they try and make tom's
parents be important but i kind of like
that they're
not everyone has to be involved in some
crazy conspiracy right like it's just
yeah this formative thing that this
young lad has gone through there is you
know comic precedent for peter parker's
parents being like you know some super
spies yeah but like it makes peter less
special if he comes from you know a sort
of special line right yeah
family i remember at one point sony was
even thinking about having like an aunt
may solo film and i was like we don't
need that we don't why i wonder if
andrew will you know it'll be like to
toby and tom be like did you guys find
the secret subway car with all the tech
inside of it no not your parents that
was just what that was just my weird
parents
they're like what
you don't find the secret messages from
your parents
imagine they all look just they go and
they find the same switches
like oh my god
of course we have of the green goblins
as well because those are our constant
throughout the movies or at least uh the
first two anyway right um we we haven't
seen norman harry or oscorp yet in the
mcu but we have a sort of inkling that
you know norman will be appearing in um
no way home so it's probably gonna be a
variant but we don't really know what's
gonna go on with that one it is weird we
haven't had like any hint of any of the
osborne's anywhere in the mcu now is the
perfect time because now that tony stark
is gone but there is a vacuum for
another industry leader like norman
osborne to pop up yet but of course
harry died in toby's universe right so
like you know we're probably not gonna
see him moving forward but could tom be
persuaded to be on the lookout for
osborne's in his universe because
osborne seemed to be a problem for
peters so i'm sure that they would talk
about how like yeah osborne's are no
good you should just watch out for their
loss boards bro
heads up i mean it's also not 100 clear
how like norman osborne from the toby
universe would even get here because
he's dead yeah unless whatever
convergence is happening here pulls them
from different points in time alfred
molina said like his daca comes from
like that moment when he's like falling
into the water right with the weird
portaly thing he was making with his
arms and his
he was making a son okay so we have like
potentially like living norman osborne
from the toby verse and maybe he's
looking for himself here maybe a willem
de maybe this is another case where like
you have variants that look the same
like what if there is a norman osborn in
the mcu and it is like willem dafoe hey
you gotta kill spiderman i'm crazy
hurry up and kill him i'm like this this
norman
son of a [ __ ] still just like owning a
business is like i don't know what
you're talking about buddy we make bikes
we make the world's best bicycles the
osborne cycle he's like oh we got a
it would be hilarious if like they kept
up with that that mirror theme from
those spider-man movies
this is variant
it's like ah you gotta kill spotify
there's no mirror and then they touch
hands and they're like we're both real
and then they kiss i mean
oh man i'd watch that movie
green goblin
well there was that bomb we kind of saw
in falcon and winter soldier right that
a lot of people were like this looks
like a pumpkin bomb
so
i mean it would be weird that there was
an oscar that's big and popular we
haven't heard about maybe they're more
secretive in the mcu or something what
happened to the harry osborn in the
andrew garfield universe he's still
alive he was alive at the end of it
right he he was alive i think that he
was probably like checked in or like oh
they took him they took him to
ravencraft that's right so you could
have like a norman osborne from the toby
verse who's mad that his son james
franco is dead my son james franco is
dead
and he finds out like his son is alive
in like uh andrew's universe he's like i
want to go there and get my son and then
we'll fly around together and have weird
faces
like sort of like into the spider-verse
type of yeah yeah i mean this is very
into the spider verse really laid a lot
of the groundwork here god bless that
movie lastly of course we have venom
flash thompson and j jonah jameson who
appear in all you know all these movies
pretty much yeah with flash uh flash is
very different from his past two
counterparts in the mcu because he's a
lot more involved in in peter parker's
life and he's really really fun
[Applause]
what's up penis parker
but we haven't seen him become the flash
thompson in the comics
or deal with like the venom symbiote and
it doesn't seem like that's going to
happen here but i really hope that we
see uh our mcu flash with venom at some
point yeah that would just be funny
let's talk about the flashes for a
second because you're right the flash
from the mcu he's
he's nicer i would say he's nicer he's a
bully but he's not like a physical bully
like uh i mean we were talking about old
people in high school the flash thompson
in the first spider the first toby
spider-man is a 40 year old man yeah who
plays or we're gonna leave football in
canada or something like that he's huge
and he's just he wants to beat up he's
he's a tough guy he's got a little bit
of an attitude it makes me wonder like
what the mcu's flash how he would like
deal with all this knowledge if he
somehow got it right if he's like wait
there's other versions of me and they
get to be venomous they could just have
like this
because i think you're right that flash
thompson from the mcu would totally take
it he'd be like yeah give me that suit
i'm sick of spider-man
monkey getting all the credit i want to
be flying around doing my thing yeah
that would be nuts like because like in
the comics a flash thompson becomes
venom and he goes off on space
adventures for a little bit it'd be
crazy to see that flash on like a new
guardians of the galaxy team with the
venomous
i would love that so much but yes uh
like i alluded to earlier of course jay
jonah james seems to be a staple in the
rain reverse of course and in the mcu
and mcu jay jonah is confirmed to be
different from the toby versus jay jonah
this time around yeah i mean that's why
that's what jk simmons said right he's
like this is a different jay jones
that's why they have different hair uh i
mean i hope i hope that two jay jonas
meet somehow wouldn't that be so great i
really do they talked it would just be
so funny it would be hilarious and i
also hope since we are doing
spider-verse it's inevitable that we do
get a jay jonah jamie since spider-man
because like if there's a deleted scene
or i don't know if that was in the
actual uh spider-man one or two where uh
jay jonah is like
oh yeah he's like pretending he's like
spider-man he's pretending to be
spider-man let's just bring that right
into the spider-man that'd be hilarious
all the j-jonas combined forces and make
one daily bugle whose sole purpose is to
[ __ ] talk spider-man that's all it is
the multiverse daily view
the multi-bugle let's do it multiverse
news the multi-bugle i mean i'm sure
that all three of these tobys have a lot
to talk about when they inevitably meet
but those are pretty much the core
things that i'm sure they're going to be
really interesting like when they do
have those conversations because they're
really big things web shooters osbournes
who don't like it's it's going to be
really because it's so weird that we're
going to see a spider-man who hasn't
gone through all the things that andrew
and toby have gone through so it's gonna
just be like whoa like now you guys are
sort of being like a next you're
changing my path with my destiny right i
totally agree mt and uh you know this
movie i hope it has some action
sequences but if it's just everyone
sitting around a table talking i i'd
watch it how fortunate for the mcu
spider-man to potentially get guidance
from other spider-man right to be uh
exactly it could make him very powerful
and help him step up and one thing
you've talked about mt and we didn't
really cover it or the mcu spider-man
might be interested in like tony's tony
starks from the other universes where he
could potentially be alive right right
yes it's very possible that you know he
could try to
make our mcu safer again by trying to
just grab a tony from one universe and
be like you don't need to study right
i'm just gonna take it all right i'll
take that it's mine
or even just to like talk to him and get
some advice right but anyways before we
continue with the show you should check
out our most recent addition to our
latest obsession line of shirts inspired
by marvel's what if it's a very cool
design it's what you with a really
stylized look look he's bald on my chest
i'm bald up here and bald down here it's
great and it's a very limited edition
shirt so you gotta grab one quick and
we've also got a full line of suicide
squad merch including a great king shark
jaws inspired shirt so grabbing
something from the new
rockstarsmerch.com store is an awesome
way to support the channel and get some
nods of approval from cool strangers
because that's what we do kang gang all
day before we dive into our bite size
questions next some words from the folks
that help make big question possible
folks like meundies it's fall and here
at new rockstars we're looking forward
to some cooler weather and some big
movies and there's also the pumpkin
spice lattes the leaves changing the
colors and all the other great seasonal
stuff it's the coziest time of year find
your comfort in undies loungewear and
more with me undies because meundies
believes that comfort is about more than
just what's touching your skin it's
about feeling comfortable in your skin
imagine the softest thing you've ever
felt in your life now imagine that same
thing but on your butt now you're
thinking about me undies now you're
using miandi's logic designed by the
country's top softness scientist to be
the softest thing you have ever worn
period from undies to loungewear these
fabrics are breathable light and almost
irresponsibly cozy very responsible you
will fall asleep in these undies really
you might not be able to stop lounging
on the couch seriously you've been
warned and it's available in sizes extra
small through 4xl in a variety of
classic colors and iconic prints so if
you have a small booty we got you
covered and me undies will have your
back and your butt all fall along but
when winter comes they're gone they will
not come just kidding they will cover
you all year long that's what this
miandi's does so to get 50 off your
first order free shipping and a 100
satisfaction guarantee go to
meundies.com bigquestion that is
meundies.com
big question this video is also
sponsored by kiwiko kiwiko is defining
the future of play by making it engaging
enriching and seriously fun they make
super cool hands-on projects and toys
designed to expose kids to concepts and
steam that's science technology
engineering art and math they're a great
resource for learning at home each
monthly crate is designed by experts
tested by kids and teaches new themes
through hands-on learning and fun a
thousand plus hours go into developing
every single crate come on that's a lot
of hours kiwico offers subscription
crates for kids of all ages from the
panda crate for toddlers all the way up
to the maker and eureka crates that are
good for teens and adults here at new
rock stars eric and our own teen
off-screen producer zack have both had a
lot of fun with some of those more
advanced crates zach recently put
together a motorized pencil sharpener
and our office pencils have never been
sharper the crates are convenient and
include everything you need so you don't
need to worry about running out for
extra supplies they come with an
educational magazine filled with content
to learn even more about that crate's
theme go to kiwico.com big question to
get 50 off your order that's kiwico.com
bigquestion for 50 off your order thank
you for that brandon well moving on to
our bite size questions next i got a
question for you brandon you ready for
this hit me with a bite-sized question
big t
now brandon
is king shark from the suicide squad
part human in park shark or just all
shark and this comes from a flaming on
on twitter and that on has two zeros
because it's very clever king shark or
nanawe made his first full appearance uh
in dc comics way back in 1994 in
superboy number nine he did technically
have a small cameo a few months before
that and superboy number zero if you
want to get technical and say bad things
about me in the comments but that's he
really showed up on super boy number
nine okay in his original appearance
king shark's mythical origins present
him as the humanoid form of a shark son
of a samoan shark god okay right so
dwayne the rock johnson gotcha yeah
our own shotgun so there is some
indication uh that he's a descendant of
a human and a shark but that line of
reasoning is never really explored in
the comic books um there's some thinking
that the mythical origins are just like
a superstition that the locals have uh
and that is just really some sort of
strange like marine mutation and then
when they kind of changed everything in
the new 52
uh king shark he got a new look you have
he was a hammerhead shark instead of a
great white uh but you know i think the
great white looks a lot better than a
hammerhead shark and apparently better
this is a little side note apparently
like james gunn tested some ideas of
using like a hammerhead shark version of
king shark uh but the eyes because
they're on the side it was really hard
for the actors it looks so weird nowhere
to look they're like it would look weird
the gray white looks great i love those
like black eyes he has it's so great in
that new 52 era he's officially the son
of
kamo a hawaiian guy and then king shark
has also appeared
in like live action before the suicide
squad he showed up in the arrowverse uh
where he was confirmed to be a mutated
metahuman named shea lambdan
uh okay this invalidates like his whole
divine background i think it's less fun
to be like oh he's definitely this human
who was like mutated right right it's
kind of more fun if he's like this sharp
i feel like king shark historically has
been a character that dc has taken a lot
of liberty as well right in terms of
like what they do with them because like
no one really cares about king shark
until you know the suicide squad and
recently harley quinn who that version
of king shark is perfect yeah i love
just a really just fun king shark but
also suicide squad of course yeah i
think the dc eu saw like the success of
groot in the marvel universe and was
like we need one of those uh
we need a group get the group guy we
need to get the group down pay for the
group gang one great please but what
about our shark boy when it comes like
to the dc eu in general because again it
wasn't really explained in the suicide
squad uh but thanks to free comic book
days suicide squad king shark number one
free comic book day baby uh that just
came out it was released on august 10th
2021 uh we might have an answer to that
in this issue which seems very closely
tied to the dceu amanda waller corrects
someone who says that king shark is half
man half shark instead she confirms that
king shark is in fact
bull shark no human in there to be found
at all he's just all shark baby um so
there's some more and jenna waller would
not lie but she needs to lie she was not
lying
except she lies all the time so that's
some more chum in the water for the
feeding frenzy of internet debate baby
let's hope we see some more king shark
in the dc
but i i think it's safe to say he's like
full sharp well thank you brandon that
was an excellent question but i got
another one for you here's another one
can thor breathe underwater and this
comes from devil egg show on twitter
thank you devilic delicious very
interesting question delicious question
um so in as guardians in general they're
like more powerful than just straight-up
humans they have enhanced strength and
speed uh they've got like regenerative
abilities uh and because of that they
live like way longer than
normal humans about like five thousand
years like an asgardian can live and
when then when you get to thor he's like
the elite of the asgardians right uh you
know he's a guy he's crossfit he does
crossfade
you know he he knows the workout of the
day what's the wod he's always saying
around asgard
you know he's he's a he's a god he's
the strongest the fastest he's the most
powerful asgardian there is uh and
thanks to his incredible stamina he
could survive just about anything except
when he gets 360 no scoped in call of
duty then he gets pissed
by new master 69 got him so we already
know that like thor can survive in space
right because after like the statesman
got destroyed he was floating around and
he bumps into the guardians who who get
there kind of soon after
it's not like he was like floating
around for months but still like he was
in the vacuum of slice for a while and
was fine he's not breathing out there
there's no air it's not so much that
like thor
can breathe underwater it's more that
like he doesn't have to breathe at all
uh
and given that he's like so strong and
so powerful he should be able to survive
like any pressures that the ocean might
put on like if he's down deep right in
the ocean right pushing on him it's not
gonna crush him because he's like pretty
strong
um yeah but additionally the comics have
established that thor doesn't even
really need to eat or drink to survive
um or at least he can go very long
periods of time without eating or
drinking and seemingly it doesn't seem
to affect his strength or abilities at
all though it has been established in
the mcu that thor loves to eat and drink
especially drink
but he doesn't have to he just does it
he does it for the thrill of it um so
yeah i don't think it's fun i if thor
took in a mouthful of water would he
drown maybe i don't know like because he
doesn't really need to eat or breathe i
guess he could choke to death
maybe if thor can take the full blast of
a star i think that he'd like swallow a
little sea water and be fine
so technically he's not breathing
underwater but he could survive
underwater for a very very long time i
mean hopefully he doesn't use the
lightning because i'm sure that'd be a
problem without cheating well like you
want to get electrocuted but yeah all
the fish all the fish would and we like
fish but now it is time for my favorite
part of the show
the box of scraps the box of scraps
scraps with a box of scraps boxes craps
now brandon i've got a question for you
okay our box of scraps question of the
day is what would you want to erase from
everyone's memory because you know
that's going to be a big part of
spiderman no way home so what would you
want doctor strange to race i mean the
easy answer is the tv show heroes right
i think it was a waste of everyone's
time
and we should just erase it from our
memories but if i were to make it where
is everything after season one the
finale season one was a disaster another
disaster okay here's something i would
erase from everyone's memory besides the
tv show heroes uh
is
in high school i was in a great
production of little shop of horrors
and i played mr mushnik who is the man
who owns the shop um i think i did a
pretty good job except i was trying to
pull off a yiddish accent for the for
the production um and i'm pretty sure i
sounded mostly like dracula the whole
time where i was just like seymour you
can't have says plants inside the shop
let me see your blood see both
i want to drink your blood seymour uh so
yeah
i'm sure that was not fun for people to
have to sit through
uh
i'm sure a lot of those people would
love that two hours of their life back
so yeah i would like to erase that from
everyone's memory but then if that's at
all possible that is a really good one
and actually you just reminded me of my
memory that i want to race and like if
this is
sort of uh you know topical considering
that alfred molina is uh you know in
coming up in this next movie i was uh in
filler on the roof and i played in high
school and i played laser wolf and uh
there's a clip on the internet with uh
alpha bolita singing if i was a rich man
okay if i were a wealthy man
and like you know this is you know
teenage mt i'm not you know omari when i
say oh mario like that's the hottest
singer right now i'm not oh mario
i've never heard of them
so i don't know what you're talking
about yeah he was he was hot back in the
day like if you don't know oh mario now
it's totally fine but yeah i'm not some
amazing singer but like it was very
embarrassing for me and uh i probably
would want everyone to uh just forget
that it even happened because it was uh
quite terrible
actually it wasn't that bad but i would
love to see
fiddler on the roof starring mts tevye
that would be incredible
i was laser wolf the one that doesn't
get the girl
i want to see you as tapia i want to see
you as tevye apatavia that's what the t
stands for master tab mr jackson
well that is it for this episode of big
question i of course want to thank
off-screen producer brandon for coming
in and teaching us a lot of things thank
you brandon you are the best thank you
mt i feel like i've learned a lot and i
have so much excitement for spider-man
no way home we know all about toby's
tubes now we know about these two
you can of course follow brandon at
grindenberric on twitter he's amazing
please do you can follow me at
mastertainment on twitter but most
importantly please follow new rockstars
wherever we are on the internet but when
you do on youtube make sure you hit that
notification bell so you get
notifications whenever we upload dope
[ __ ] which is very constantly so do that
but anyway thank you guys so much for
watching we love you goodbye
[Music]
you